so we're very close to the last month of
2017 and 2017 has been I mean I think
I'm not exaggerating at all when I say
2017 has been a great year for the show
in terms of audience we surpassed the
four hundred thousand subscriber mark on
YouTube we've had a record year in terms
of podcast downloads we now have more
radio and television affiliates than
ever in the history of the show free
speech TV which is on DirecTV and Dish
Network and broadcast the show has
picked up our show now for five days a
week we started the year with only four
of our weekly episodes on free speech TV
and now they're carrying all five but
there's also been some pretty bad stuff
this year at the top of the list as
YouTube D monetization ad pocalypse
which started sort of March 31st April
1st and initially took 99% of our
YouTube revenue and still is crushing us
although a fraction of the revenue has
come back just a few weeks ago we had
our Amazon affiliate link was which was
contributing about 10 to 15 10 to 12
percent depending on the month of our
total revenue that was completely and
totally shut down by Amazon and we now
have a new platform that I want to tell
you about that is already generating
some revenue for the program and really
has a huge potential to grow and for
people who have been with us through the
the ad pocalypse you've heard me mention
that I'm endlessly 5 or 10 a week
getting emails from people saying David
put the David Pakman show on this
platform or put the David Pakman show on
that platform and you'll be able to
recover some of that lost revenue and I
investigate every single one of those
and typically I end up coming away with
the idea that either the audience is way
too small to actually generate any
revenue for the show or that it's a
platform that actually exposes us to the
exact same types of problems that led to
YouTube's D monetization in the first
place and I am now coming to you to tell
you we're on a new platform and at
absolutely no cost without paying
anything you can help us generate
revenue on that platform
and the platform is steam it okay in
that spelled st double e m.i.t ste e MIT
dot-com is the website and one of the
great things about the steam it platform
is that our revenue becomes
disaggregated from the ads that run on
our videos and also from some algorithm
that determines is this content okay to
run ads or not our revenue on the steam
it platform actually depends on whether
viewers and and curators of the content
as they're known on steam it up vote our
content and as you know with YouTube
there are algorithms that determine
whether the content is sensitive or
controversial and that's determined by
YouTube and if that happens no ads run
and all the time that we spent making a
video for you researching a topic doing
a story it ends up making no money and
with steam it there is not that type of
censorship the determining factor as to
whether we are able to make money from
our content is whether users upload the
content and the system is reputation
based meaning that users with more
participation in the system provide more
money when they upvote content so as an
example when i first join the platform
if I as a user up voted other content I
would provide only a fraction of a penny
in revenue to the content creator I've
been on the platform just over three
weeks and because my reputation has
grown now an upvote from me is worth
five cents now it might not sound like
much but the difference between five
cents and a fraction of a penny is an
exponential increase in just the first
three weeks and here's the great thing
and here's why I'm coming to you with
this because of the scale of our
audience including our YouTube channel
which now has about four hundred and ten
thousand subscribers we could do really
well on this platform if our YouTube
audience comes over even only one or two
percent of our YouTube audience and I
actually ran the numbers
if just 1% of our existing audience
meaning just to use the YouTube numbers
even though we've got the podcast and
the radio show in free speech TV if
4,100 of our 410 thousand YouTube
subscribers just 1% came over to steam
it and only one half of that 1%
regularly upvoted our content on steam
it meaning about about two thousand up
votes for each piece of content we post
to steam it we would do so well on the
platform that we would forget about the
problems of Amazon cutting our affiliate
link we could forget about the problem
of YouTube's D monetization and ad
pocalypse and the that's the way it
works and not only that but users can
also contribute their own content to the
community they can also earn based on
their comments comments and posts that
they make so what you can do is really
simple go to steam it com
that's ste e MIT comm create a new free
account follow us there at steam it com
slash @ sign David Pakman and then
upload our content that's all you have
to do and ideally participate in the
community more generally since there is
a lot of really great content on it
yesterday I was on a program that that
is a it's a steam it community program
called MSP waves which you can also find
out more about let's do this thing okay
this is a really exciting opportunity
and it's already been generating on a
smaller scale some revenue for the show
and at no cost to you you can help us
get beyond YouTube's D monetization
issue and the Amazon affiliate link
thing so check out the link if you're
watching this clip on YouTube in the
youtube description if not go to steam
at.com slash at david pakman show create
a free account let's do this thing